الينا منها طاي جنوب تركيا موفضه العربيه
زميل عمار هندي مرحبا بك عمار الصوره التي
تاتي منها طاير تركز
تركز اليوم على المقابر الجماعيه صحيح ان
هناك مشهد متعلق باستمرار عمليات الانقاذ
ولكن يبدو ان هناك فقدان امل في هذه
المدينه في وجود احياء
يعني نحن نتحدث عن فقدان الامل والامل
يكمن هنا رشا هذه حاله استخراج فتاه تحت
الانقاض تاكدنا بانها حيه
تاكدت فرق الانقاذ ساطلب من الزميل المصور
ان يلتف الى الكاميرا ما حدث هنا في هذا
الموقع بان فتاه سمع رجال الانقاذ هنا
حركه من تحت الانقاض قاموا بابلاغ
الرجال الانقاذ الاخرين بالاجهزه المتطوره
جاؤوا الى هذا المكان وحينما
تحدثوا اليها وطلبوا منها ان تحدث صوتا
معينا ردات فعل معينه تجيب فيها على
اسئلتهم بالفعل
اجابت على اسئلتهم وتاكدوا انها حيه بعد
ذلك جاء جهاز طبقي متطور يرصد الصوت قاموا
باسئله بسؤالها مره اخرى هذه الفتاه التي
تحت الالقاب الان
قاموا بسؤالها مره اخرى واجابت من خلال
الطرق حينما مثلا هل تسمعينني تطرق ثلاث
مرات واجابها بالفعل ومن اخبرني بذلك
الضابط المسؤول عن الجهاز
هو الضابط المسؤول عن الجهاز الذي يعمل به
لفحص ما اذا كانت هنالك اصوات على ايه حال
انا للتو سالت منقده كم يستغرقون من الوقت
قالت لي اقل من ساعه اقل من ساعه يكون
يكون تكون فرق الانقاذ وصلت اليها
هم يطلبون الصمت الان منا نعم اذا سيصمت
زميلي عمار هندي فيها طاي جنوب تركيا في
هذه اللحظات بناء على اشارات من رجال
الانقاذ اعتدنا هذا المشهد في عدد من
المدن التركيه
لرجال الانقاذ وهم يظهرون هذه التعليمات
بين الحين والاخر وذلك لاعطاء الفرصه
لسماع صوت الناجين تحت الانقاذ ان ربما
هذا يساعد في عمليه الاخراجهم هذا المشهد
المتكرر في الاخبار على مدى اليومين
الماضيين لما يشبه وصفا بالمعجزات يحدث
بالفعل على الارض من خلال خروج بعض
الناجين بين الحين والاخر زميلي عمار هندي
يرصد في هذه اللحظات منها طاء جنوب تركيا
انباء عن خروج طفله من تحت هذه الانقاض
بعد ان تم تواصل بين وبين رجال انها طفله
رشحه بعد لم يتاكد انها طفله وربما انثى
ولكن لم نتاكد انها طفله هي انثى ربما
سيده لا اعلم ولكن اكيد انها حيه الحمد
لله واخبروني بذلك وهم الان طبعا سياره
الاسعاف تنتظرها لنقلها فور اخراجها قاموا
بجلب قطع خشبيه لم افهم ما سبب قطعوها
قطاع معينه وادخلوها الى داخل الحفره التي
يعملون فيها تمهيدا لاخراج هذه الفتاه
طبعا كل المؤشرات الحياه موجوده عند هذه
الفتاه وهي مدركه بمعنى حينما يسالوها اي
سؤال تجيب عليه من خلال الطرق او من خلال
الحركه باصبعها حسب ما اخبرني الضابط
المسؤول عن الجهاز المستخدم لرصد الاصوات
والحركه تحت الانقاض نعم رشا هل هناك اي
من اهالي هؤلاء الضحايا موجودون في موقع
الحادث هل هناك حاله من هذه الفتاه التي
ستخرج هي ابنه من شقيقه من اخت من زوجه من
ابنه من يعني في هذه اللحظات اعتدنا ان
هناك طرق
نعم رشا اسمعك تفضل عمار
لا لا كنت اقول لك انا هنالك حاله من
الترقب من رجال الاسعاف والانقاذ وساطلب
من الزميل ان ينتف بالكاميرا هذه سياره
الاسعاف تنتظر هنا فرق الاسعاف الاخرى
تنتظر اخراج هذه الفتاه من تحت الانقاض
وطبعا ستكون هنالك اضاءه اعتقد انها وصلت
الاضاءه الى مكان حيث يتم
فحص امكانيه وكيفيه اخراجها من تحت
الانقاض ولكن الاسر لا وجود لاي اسره هنا
لم اعثر على اي احد من اقربائها هم يعني
هي هذا المبنى مكون من طبقات سقط بالكامل
والفتاه على ما يبدو انها في الطابق
الاخير يعني هي تبدو يبدو انها تسكن في
الطابق الاخير وربما لذلك تمكن رجال
الانقاذ من سماعها او الاستدلال على
وجودها
في خلال عملياتهم في هذا المبنى من
الاستنفار الكبير تبدو من خلفك عم لرجال
الانقاذ هناك من يقدر كثيرا نعم استنفروا
وجلبوا الاضاءه
هم جلبوا اضاءه قويه ليتسنى لهم العمل على
اخراجها بسهوله وهم فعلا مستنفرون لانه
هنالك اجهزه لقطع الحديد هنالك كما قلت لك
قطع خشبيه عريضه وهذه الاضويه وهنالك على
ما يبدو سيدخل الضوء الى داخل النفق الذي
يعملون فيه انا حاولت نحن على سقف المبنى
ولكن حاولت الاقتراب اكثر
لكنهم منعوني من ذلك هناك اجراءات وساحاول
مره اخرى لاقتراب لمشاهده الصوره
انا ساصعد لمحاوله مشاهده الصوره اكثر
ولكن اذا طلبوا مني العوده ساعود
انتبه بس انتبه
اه هنالك هم يعني ما يقومون به الان
هو فتح الغرفه يبدو التي تتواجد فيها
الفتاه رشا
ساطلب من الزميل المصور ان تشاهد الصوره
عن قرب
اذا الزميل عمار هندي نجح في الاقتراب من
هذه البؤره تحديدا التي يعمل عليها
يحاولون على ما يبدو الدخول الى غرفتها
للفتاه
كما تلاحظين رشا هم احدث فتحه في السقف
للدخول الى الفتاه والعمل جاري من الفتحه
ومن الجانب الاخر
للفتحه الثانيه الى غرفتها الى حيث توجد
هذه الفتاه تحت الانقراض بالتاكيد عمليه
صعبه ومعقده للغايه لذلك نشاهد هذا العدد
الكبير في هذه طبعا معقده جدا
نعم الكلمه الصحيحه هم مستنفرون فعلا كما
قلت لاخراجها على قيد الحياه لانه كما
تعلمي هم يصادقون الزمن في حالات كثيره
نحن وقفنا عليها كانت كل الاشارات اشارات
الحياه موجوده لدى اشخاص تحت الانقاض ولكن
حينما يعني بعد ساعات استغرق الامر للاسف
يكون استغرق ثلاث ساعات حينما يصلون الى
الشخص تحت
يحاول ان يقترب اكثر فاكثر لينقل لنا اقرب
مدى لهذه العمليه التي يقوم بها رجال
الانقاذ فيها تاي
صحيح صحيح نحن نحاول ان نكون معكم ثانيه
بثانيه تشاهد بالتحديد ما الذي يجري هنا
كانت زميل عمار هندي اشار وهو معنا الان
على الهواء الى ان رجال الانقاذ وجدوا
طريقهما
ارسال اشارات لهذه الفتاه يتم طرح بعض
الاسئله عليها وتقوم هي بالرد عبر بعض
الطرقات فيفهموا منها انها ما زالت على
قيد الحياه وبالتالي حدث هذا الاستنفار في
هذا الموقع لاخراج هذه الفتاه
طبعا رشا مع الملاحظه بان احد
قالوا انها الفتاه تحت المبنى يعني من اين
جاءت المعلومه انها فتاه او حسب ما اخبرني
حسب ما اخبرني رجل رجل ضابط الامن اضابط
سلاح الهندسه الذي قام بالفحص اخبرني نعم
هنالك اصوات
اجابني فانا لا اعلم ان كان صوتها او صوت
الجهاز ولكن هو كان يعني مبتسم وفرح جدا
لانه استطاع ان يحدد ان هنالك اصوات نعم
لننظر الى التعقيدات المرتبطه بهذه
العمليه نعم عمار اسمعك واحاول ان اعرف
منك بعض المعلومات عمليات الحفر تتم من
جانبين وليس من جانب واحد يعني نحن نجد
عمال الناحيه وفي المقابل من الناحيه
الاخرى ايضا عمال انقاذ اخرين العمق الذي
يمكن الوصفه الى الناس
صحيح صحيح هم يحاولون الدخول اليها كانت
بدايه العمليات من السقف فتحوا احدثوا
فتحه في السقف دخلوا اليها ومن ثم من تحت
السقف من الجانب الاخر
ادخل احد رجال لانقاذ وهو انا اراه دخل
الى تحت سقف البيت
نعم هذا المشهد تكرر كثيرا وبالمناسبه لا
احد يستطيع ان نعم كنت اتحدث ان هذا
المشهد قرر على مدار الايام الماضيه ولا
احد يستطيع ان يحدد اللحظه تحديدا التي
يخرج فيها الناجي لان الامر يرتبط بجهود
على الارض في الوصول اليه مئه بالمئه
مئه بالمئه صحيح صحيح لا يستفيد ان نتابع
هذه الصوره او اللحظه نعم نتابع معك
الصوره ونطرح عليك بعض الاسئله ايضا عمار
عن المشهد العام كنا نتحدث انا وانت
بالامس بعض البنايات والاخرى قائمه
التحقيقات التركيه التي تجرى اليوم في
وسائل الاعلام التركيه يتم التركيز على
انه تم القبض على عدد من المقاولين الذين
لم يلتزموا بالاشتراطات الخاصه بالمباني
وانا هذه المحاكمات ستتم سريعا وفقا
لتصريحات العدل التركي دعنا في الصوره حول
هذا الامر
صحيح بالامس كان احد رجال الاعمال ويملك
مجمعات سكنيه هنا في هاتاي وانا زرتها وكل
البنايات التي يمتلكها هو سقطت كامله
وبشكل يعني مرعب ولم تحتمل يعني مده مده
تحملها للزلزال كانت خفيفه جدا وبذلك كان
على وشك ان يفر من احد مطارات تركيا
العامله وفي تلك اللحظه القوا القبض عليه
وبالتالي احلوه الى القضاء بانه لم يعتمد
المعايير اللازمه في البناء او انه تسبب
ذلك بانهيار تلك البنايات التي يمتلكها
وهذا الامر يعني يبدو ان السلطات التركيه
ستواجه هذا الامر مع كثير من المقاولين
لانه هنالك بنيات بالفعل لم تدمر ولما
تصاب باي اذى ولكن هنالك بنيات اخرى دمرت
بشكل كامل وسريع على ايه حال السؤال
المطروح لماذا تنها وبنايات اخرى لا تنهار
وما سبب انهيار بنايه على الرجال الانقاذ
هذا موضوع مهم جدا يعني شاهدنا ورايت
بعيني رجال انقاذ يعملون في بنايات للسقوط
في سبيل الوصول الى شخص تحت تسويه هذا
المبنى وهذا كان فيه خطر كبير وللاسف يعني
هذا الفيديو الذي ظهر لبنايه تنهار على
رجال الانقاض هم كانوا يعملون فيها رغم
انها غير منهاره ولكن يعني لم يتخلوا في
الحقيقه هم لم يتخلوا وبالتالي عملوا رغم
المخاطر هذا هذا عدد هذه البنايات رشا
الايل الاليه الايه للسقوط والمهدده
بالانهيار والمدمره بشكل جزئي من اي من
جراء الزلزال كبير جدا
بعض المعلومات التي ظهرت
على مدى الايام الماضيه يعني بها عدد من
السواحل وبالتالي هي مدينه مهمه سياحيه
يتم التعويل عليها كثيرا حدثت بها
انشقاقات للارض بشكل كبير كيف هي المشاهد
العامه المحيطه بهذه المدينه
كما تعلمين ميناء اسكندرون هو موجود في
هاتاي واحد اكبر الموانئ التركيه المعتمد
عليها طبعا اشتعل واحترق بشكل كامل وهنالك
تصدعات في كل مكان يعني في هذا في هذه
المدينه حتى وزير الصحه التركي بالامس اكد
بانها تاي هي او انطاكيا هي المدينه التي
اتواجد فيها الان وفي وسطها هي اكثر مدينه
دمرت رغم ان مثلا قهرمان مرعش هي مركز
الزلزال لكنها لم تدمر كما دمرت انطاكيا
في وسط هاتاي المدينه رشا المشهد فيها
مرعب في الحقيقه مرعب جدا ومدمره بالكامل
وهنالك احياء كامله كامله باكملها دمرت
اليوم كنت انا في حي سكني مدمر بالكامل
والتقيت شاب التقيت العديد من الناس
التقيت شاب سوري اكد لي ان 30 من اقاربه
وافراد اسرته في مبنى لم تتم حتى اللحظه
عمليات الانقاذيه
انت الان عمار على الهواء يعني التقديرات
التركيه كانت تشير الى ان هاتاي وحدها
تكبدت ثلث ضحايا هذا الزلزال
صحيح صحيح هذا الشاب اليوم اخبرني
بالحرف قال لي ما بستنى حدا عايش بدي
جثثهم ادفنها يعني هو لا يريد سوى ان يدفن
اقاربه اعطوني جثث ادفنها وصل به الحال
الى هذا الحد طبعا حينما استفسرنا هنالك
طبعا يعني عدد طب نقص كبير في رجال
الانقاذ والامكانيات وهذا معروف للجميع
ولكن حينما استفسرنا هنالك اولويه
للبنيات المدمره التي فيها اصوات احياء
ولكن السؤال هنا رشا يكمن كيف يستدل على
يعني صوت اشخاص تحت الانقاض احياء
وهل يوزعوا فرق على كل البنايات لفحص هذا
الامر بالتاكيد لا ولكن احيانا يتم سماع
اصوات اشخاص بشكل عشوائي ويعني صدفه
واحيانا كثيره هنالك من ينادي وينادي
لساعات طويله ويصرخ ولا يسمعه احد المدينه
مدمره بالكامل فحينما يخرج
من هذه المدينه على قيد الحياه بعد سته
ايام او يعني على وشك ان ينتهي اليوم
السادس هذا امل كبير جدا
ومهم جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت استطيع ان
اقول لك ان اكثر غالبيه من التقيتهم فقدوا
الامل فيما يتعلق بالعثور على احياء
المشكله اكبر ايضا في انطاكيا تحديدا كما
انت ذكرت على الهواء الان هاتاي
وانطقي تحديدا هي المحافظه الاكثر تضررا
من هذا الزلزال وفقا لتقديرات وزير
الداخليه التركي هناك بعض المعلومات لا
اعلم اذا كانت صحيحه ام لا يتم نشرها عن
انها المنطقه او التربه او الارض في هذه
المنطقه التي حدث فيها زلزال بدات تتحرك
نحو الغرب
واضح ان عمار لا يسمعني ربما
ونحن سنبقى كما تشاهدون حضراتكم في متابعه
حيه ومباشره
لجهود فرق الانقاذ في مدينه هاتاي التركيه
لمحاوله
اخراج فتاه او طفله لم يعرف مراسل العربيه
على وجه التحديد عمرها لان هذا امر صعب
بالطابع ولكن كانت هناك اشارات قد اصدرتها
هذه الفتاه او هذه الطفله وفهم منها رجال
الالقاب وبالتالي يتم العمل على هذه
العمليه بشكل
كبير كما تشاهدون حاله الصنفار من موقع
الحادث اعود مره اخرى الى زميلي عمار تفضل
عمار
عمار لا يسمعني ربما تكون هناك قد طلبت
منهم ساعات يعني لحظات صمت يحدث هذا عاده
هم يقومون الان
بمحاوله اخراج هذه الفتاه كما تشاهدوني
عمليه معقده للغايه يتم فيها التعامل وفقا
لمراسل العربيه باجهزه متطوره
واجهزه تقليديه ايضا هذه النقطه تحديدا
كانت حكومه اردوغان قد تحدثت عنها في
الساعات القليله جدا الماضيه بانها نجحت
وفقه فرق من دول عديده في الاستعانه
باجهزه حديثه
لعمليات الانقاذ تتم بشكل اسرع بشكل ادق
القدره على الوصول على او الحصول على عدد
من الناجين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه وهذا
الامر كان صعبا وفقا لتصريحات اردوغان في
الاولى هو نفسه قال انه كانت هناك حاله من
الارتباك لم يكن احد يتوقع حجم الكارثه من
هذا النوع الا ان عمليه احتواء لتداعيات
هذا الزلزال تتم بشكل افضل مع مرور الايام
نتيجه الدعم الفني نتيجه المساعدات نتيجه
الاداره التي بدات تتفاعل مع الحادث اعود
مره اخرى الى زميلي عمار عمار هناك ما
زالت حاله الاستنفار هي العنوان الرئيسي
لهذه الصور
صحيح صحيح هم مستنفرون وهنالك تعزيزات
تاتي في سبيل الوصول الى هذه الفتاه تحت
الانخاض ويعني يسابقون الزمن كل ما
يحتاجونه من امكانيات اليات اضاءه عناصر
كل شيء حتى الطريقه للدخول اليها وصلوا
الى كل ما يحتاجونه وهم الان في الطريق
الى هذه الفتاه في الطريق الى فتاه امضت
سته ايام تحت الانقاض وقاتلت على ما يبدو
صامده حتى تعود للحياه من جديد يعني هذا
ما يحدث الان نحن على وشك ان تخرج امامنا
او خلال الفتره التي يعني القادمه الساعه
القادمه لانه حينما سالت قلب قبل نصف ساعه
كم تحتاجون من الوقت قالوا خلال ساعه ان
تخرج هذه الفتاه الى الحياه مجددا يعني
ومن ثم لو سالها احد ستكون لها روايه
غريبه جدا ومؤثره جدا وتفاصيل اللحظات
كلياتها ستكون يعني شيء يستحق ان يستمع
اليه الانسان بصمت لان كل شخص خرج رشا من
تحت الانقاذ لديه مليون روايه وروايه
يكتبها عن تلك اللحظات التي عاشها تحت
الانقاض وانا وانا كنت التقيت شاب
ابضى 36 ساعه تحت الانقاض وكانت يعني
روايه
مؤثره جدا كيف في لحظه ما تخلى عن الشعور
بالحاجه الى الطعام او الشراب ولم يفكر
سوى في الاحتماء من البرد باي طريقه لان
البرد كان اكبر شيء يهدد حياته نعم
بالمناسبه هاتاي من اولى المدن والمناطق
التي تحرك اليها اردوغان سريعا والمسؤولين
الاتراك لان حجم الدمار بها كان كبيرا
للغايه كما ذكر زميلي عمار لذلك حاله
الاستنفار الكبرى كانت في هاتاي وفي وس
الاعلام التركيه حينما تكتب هاتاي يكتب
بجانبها المدينه المنكوبه هي الاكثر تضررا
على ما يبدو مما حدث تفضل عمار
صحيح اردوغان كان ازار لواء اسكندرون
والاحزاب السياسيه المعارضه وغيرها زارت
هذه المدينه
وتواجدت في اماكن الدمار لانها المدينه
باتت حكايه التركيه يعني لانه المدينه
مدمره بالكامل ومنكوبه بطريقه مرعبه طبعا
في على الصعيد الانساني هنالك دعم يعني
يصل الى من تبقوا او من يعمل او من ينتظر
اقاربه في هذه المدينه هنالك توفير
للبطانيات
للاشخاص الذين يبيتون في الشوارع والطرقات
هنالك طبعا اشكرك يا عمار على اثاره هذه
النقطه حدثنا في هذا الجزء عن المساعدات
التي يتم دعم فعلا لانها جزء مهم
فعلا فعلا لانها جزء مهم جدا هذه
المساعدات تاتي رشا على شكل مخيمات
في اطراف هاتاي قاموا بانشاء مخيمات للناس
التي تشردت من منازلها من جراء الزلزال
طبعا حتى سكان البنايات قاموا باخلائها لا
يسمح لاي شخص ان يسكن اي بنايه او منزل في
هاتاي لان المدينه غير قابله للعيش في
السكن في البنايات فيها هنالك طبعا توزيع
لمواد عينيه يعني في هنالك بطانيات هنالك
غذاء هنالك كل ما يحتاجه الشخص يجده في
الطرقات يعني ونحن نسير
تجد عشرات الاشخاص يوزعون طعام يوزعون
بطانيات وهذه المساعدات اعتقد انها مؤقته
من حيث الحاجه يعني هم يحتاجون اكثر من
ذلك لاعاده اعمار هذه المدينه لا ادري كيف
يعني يمكن فعلا اعاده اعمار هذه المدينه
المدمره بالكامل رغم ان الحكومه اكدت
حكومه يعني السلطات التركيه اكدت انها
ستساعد في اعاده الاعمار والسكن لكل ما
فقدوا منازلهم ولكن اعتقد ان هذا الامر
سيكون
ضخم وضخم جدا ويعني كما كما نتحدث عن بلد
على سبيل المثال دخلت في حرب ودمرت
بالكامل او دمرت اجزاء منها بالكامل
وتحتاج الى اعاده اعمار هذا يشبه الامر
تماما هذا الامر وبالتالي هنالك نعم اعطيت
تحديدا عمار كانت مركز اهتمام من اداره
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه العديد من
البيانات صدرت عاما حدث تحديدا في هاتاي
قالوا ان هذا زلزال وقع على عمق ما يقرب
من سبعه كيلو متر
هذا ما كان قد تم نشره وان مركز الزلزال
يبعد ما يقرب من 72 كيلو متر عن ساحل
هاتاي وبالتالي من الناحيه العلميه هي
الاكثر تضررا
صحيح افاد على الدوام تنشر تحذيرات عبر
صفحتها على تويتر طبعا افادي هيئه الكوارث
وطوارئ والازمات التركيه تنشر يوميا
بيانات عن الهزات الارتداديه التي تحدث
قهرمان مرعش وهاتاي اكثر المدن التي تحدث
فيها هزات ارتداديه من جراء
مشاهدينا عمار
بالمشاهد الخاصه بها طي نتذكر جميعا
المشاهد المنتشره عن ابتلاع سيارات عن
انشقاقات كبيره في الطرق هذه الصور كانت
فيها طاي اليس كذلك عمار
صحيح صحيح طبعا هنالك طريق الطريق المؤديه
الى غازي عنتاب طريق مشقوق بالكامل يعني
الطريق اختلف اختلف تماما اصبحت يعني
هنالك مسافه كبيره بين نصفي الطريق وهذا
بسبب الانشقاقات المدينه ليس يعني الان لو
استطعنا تصوير هذه المدينه من الاعلى
سنشاهد شيء مذهل وشيء صادم للغايه من جراء
من شده الدمار رقعه الدمار وانتشار هذه
الرقعه هائل جدا في هاتاي رشا وكما قلت لك
يعني هنالك خطر ايضا متواصل على هاتاي
وعلى قهرمان مرعش بسبب الهزات الارتداديه
لانه في حال لا قدر الله ان حدثت هزه
ارتداديه قويه كل البنايات كل البنايات
المتصدعه والمهدده بالانهيار ستسقط فانها
على وشك ان تعرف
عيني نعم عفوا المقاطعه عمار ولكن نحاول
ان استفيد من معلومات اكبر منك تقوم بهذه
المعايشه على مدى سته ايام الماضيه عمار
ماذا عن فرق الانقاذ ماذا عن الدعم الذي
يقدم هل هو فقط اعتماد على عناصر تركيا
اردوغان يقول اليوم رقم ان هناك ما يقرب
من 166 الف شخص في جموع هذه المحافظات
العشره يعملون على الارض هل شاهدت فود
دوليه خبراء دوليين ام انه يتم الاستعانه
بقوات الجيش التركي كما كان واضح خلال
الايام الماضيه
اليوم فقط انا رايت فرق انقاذ من جنسيات
مختلفه ورايت انقاذ كامل من استونيا رايت
فريق انقاذ كامل صيني بمعداته وسياراته
يتواجد فيها تحديدا حيث نحن ويجوب الطرقات
ويقدم المساعده في الاجهزه المتطوره رايت
فريق كوري جنوبي يعمل هنا رايت فريق روسي
يعمل هنا هنالك فرق من جنسيات مختلفه
ومتعدده وفرق كبيره يعني نتحدث نحن عن
مثلا 50 الى 100 شخص كل فريق من هذه الفرق
مع سياراتهم مع الياتهم معداتهم والاجهزه
اللازمه
للكشف عن مفقودين يعني مثلا اليوم حدثت
قصه ونحن في في بنايه اخرى يعني في مكان
اخر من انطاكيا كانت هنالك فتاه تبين
لرجال
الانقاذ وهم يعملون بان هنالك صوت تحدثوا
اليها اصدرت صوتا طلبوا دعم جاءت جاء فريق
الانقاذ التركي بجهاز مع كاميرا حاولوا
ادخال هذه الكاميرا ولكنهم كاميرا موصوله
بالسلك ولكنهم لم يتمكنوا بعد ذلك طلبوا
دعم فجاء فريق كوري جنوبي لفحص امكانيه
تواجد هذه الفتاه على قيد الحياه
ساصمت قليلا رشا
سفارات الانذار تدوي في هذه المنطقه التي
يتم العمل فيها في هاتاي المنكوبه حيث
اصدر رجال الانقاذ هذه السفارات لاعلان
لحظات الصمت بحثا عن احد او احدى الناجين
في هذه اللحظات حيث تتم العمليه وسط
استنفار كبير من رجال الانقاذ في محيط هذه
العمليه ونحن منذ قليل نتابع معكم هذه
العمليه بالصوت والصوره ونحاول ايضا ان
نلقي مع موفد العربيه النظره على المشهد
المحيط بها طاي تحديدا باعتبارها من اكثر
المدن التي تضررت بل ان محافظه
هاتاي ومدينه انطاكيا تحديدا عاصمه هذه
المحافظه هي الاكثر تضررا على الاطلاق من
هذا الزلزال وفقا لوصف وزير الداخليه
التركي مراسل عربيه كان يقول ايضا ان هناك
للدعم الفني من فرق دوليه وصلت بالفعل الى
هاتاي لمحاوله تقديم الدعم في اطار
مساعدات دوليه تقدم ليست فقط مساعدات
تتعلق من اغذيه او ادويه في كارثه من هذا
النوع يتم الاعتماد بشكل كبير جدا على
مساعدات تتعلق بمعدات واليه بعضها حديث
بعضها ثقيل خبره دوليه في عمليه الانقاذ
خبره دواريه في رفع الانقاض هذا العمل يتم
فيه الاستعانه بخبره الدوليه وكانت هناك
حاله من الانتفاضه الدوليه قد تمت من بعض
الدول لدعم تركيا في هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه الكبيره
طبعا الصوره
ستظل عالقه معنا هناك عمليات حفر على
ابعاد منخفضه على ما يبدو طبعا مفرد
العربيه من موقع الحدث كان يصمت قليلا
وفقا لتعليمات رجال الانقاذ دقائق ربما في
هذا الصمت ولكن اعتقد انه يمكن ان نعود
لنتحدث اليه مجددا عمار
نعم رجب
ما هو الجديد خلال هذه الدقائق التي تم
الصمت فيها
لا ادري حقيقه هم طلبوا من الجميع الصمت
وربما لان المنقذ المتواجد تحت السقف ربما
يتحدث مع الفتاه لا اعلم ولكن طلبوا من
الجميع وكانوا يعني يترقبوا شيء في الاسفل
ومن ثم يعني قالوا لا باس في الكلام وعادت
الاليات للعمل بشكل
كثيف مجددا نعم رشا انا اعتذر ولكن احيانا
الغبار الذي يعني غبار هذا الركام الذي
يقومون بازالته
نعم رشا انتم شركاء يعني الزملاء الصحفيين
على الارض يشاركون رجال الانقاذ هذه
اللحظات وكل ما يحيط بها من مخاطر فتحيه
واجبه لرجال الصحافه على الارض زملائي
الاعزاء شبكه مراسلي ومفيده العربيه على
الارض منذ لحظات الاولى يتابعون هذا الجهد
الكبير وعمليات الانقاذ التي تتم على
الارض مجهود كبير يعني هناك عيون لا تنام
بالفعل هي عيون المنقذين وعيون الصحفيين
بالتاكيد الذين ينقلون الحدث لحظه بلحظه
كنا نتحدث عمار ونحن نتابع الصوره نحاول
ايضا ان نتابع هذه الصوره التي تركز على
عمليه انقاذ لفتاه ولكن نحاول ان نتابع
معك الصوره الاكبر في محافظه
عمرها هل تسمعني الان
ربما هناك اجهزه للحافظ
نعم هناك بعض ادوات الحفر تتم الان ربما
تجعل من الصعبه الصوت اقول اننا نركز على
هذا المشهد ونركز ايضا على المشهد الاكبر
في هذه المدينه المنكوبه كنت تتحدث معي عن
وصول وفود دوليه للدعم الفني ماذا ايضا عن
المنكوبين الذين تم نقلهم الى اماكن اخرى
كيف تتم المساعدات والدعم لهم
ان كنت سمعت السؤال جيدا اعتقد انك
سالتيني عن المنكوبين الذين يتم توفير
خيام لهم هم يعني يتم نقلهم هنالك نوعين
النوع الاول هنالك عائلات تبقى
بالقرب المقربه من البنايه التي لا تزال
تحت الانقاض فيها اشخاص تخصهم ولا يتحركون
من هناك وفي هذه الحاله يعتمدون على النوم
في الطرقات وتاتيهم البطانيات والدعم الذي
يحتاجونه الى حيث يجلسون وهنالك النوع
الاخر لعائلات شردت يعني منهم من فقد
اسرته وتبقى لوحده ومنهم عائلات نجت
باكملها نقلوا الى هذه المخيمات على اطراف
انطاكيا انطاكيا هنا في هذه المدينه في
اماكن امنه جدا ليس فيها بنايات يعني هم
اقاموا هذه الخيام والمخيمات في تلك
المناطق ورايت ايضا بعض المخيمات في مناطق
ماهوله لانه
حسب عدد السكان وحسب
تواجدهم وانتظارهم ربما لمن يخصهم
عمار انا اعتقد كما قلت لك رشا تفضل
اسمعك نشير فقط ايضا الى المشكله المتعلقه
باستمرار الهزات الارتداديه يعني المركز
الاورو متوسطي لرصد الزلازل منذ قليل اعلن
انه تم تسجيل اربع هزات ارضيه جنوب تركيا
تتراوح درجاتها ما بين ثلاثه الى اربعه
درجات على مقياس ريختر وهذا يؤكد ان
عمليات الانقاذ تمر بتحديات كبيره ايضا
كما شاهدنا في فيديوهات سابقه انهيار هذه
الانقاذ على رجال الانقاذ وبالتالي هي
عمليه صعبه للغايه
وتحدي كبير يواجه هذه المحافظات الان
صحيح صحيح نحن يعني هنا في في هاتاي نشعر
بالهزات الارتداديه رشا بعضها ياتي قوي
الصراحه والبعضها لا لبضع ثواني فقط يعني
هيك حينما نكون في السياره مثلا او على
على سطح مبنى او في مكان ما نشعر بان
هنالك اهتزاز يشعر الشخص ان هنالك دوار
كان كان لديه دوار ولكن
هذه الهزات الارتداديه متى الخشيه منها
متى متى المشكله ستكون اذا كانت قويه
لانها للاسف ولا قدر الله ستتسبب بدمار
هائل جدا في البنايات التي على وشك ان
تنهار انا كنت اقول لك تذكرت الان كنت
اقول لك انني رايت بعض البنايات التي على
وشك ان تنهار توقفها اليات ضخمه يعني هم
يعني يقومون بدعم هذه البنايات حتى لا
تسقط باليات ضخمه
للاسف رشا انقطع الاتصال معك الان ساصمت
خشيه ان تكوني تتحدثي الي وهذه مشكله في
الاتصالات لكن اسمعك بشكل جيد نحن سنبقى
معك عمار الى ان تنتهي هذه العمليه وفقا
للمصادر التي اكدت لك ربما تاخذ ساعه مضى
منها ما يخرج من نصف ساعه لكن تحديد الاجل
الزمني لهذا الامر مساله صعبه للغايه على
ايه حال التغطيه مستمره والمتابعه مستمره
ايضا مع زميلي عمار هندي منها طاي وسيكون
معكم في الساعه المقبله
لمتابعه هذه التغطيه زميلي طالب لمتابعه
التغطيه
شكرا لرشا نتابع اعزائي المشاهدين هذه
التغطيه المتواصله عبر قناه العربيه لهذا
الزلزال المدمر والمهول الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا المشاهد الان منها طاي مع
الامال التي تتصاعد كما ينقل لنا مراسلنا
عمار الهندي
فرق الانقاذ التركيه تحاول انتشال طفله من
تحت المبنى يعني بعد مضيء اكثر من 130
ساعه المعلومات تقول بان هنالك طفله تحت
الانقاض وان هنالك استجابه من قبلها
وبالتالي تحاول فرق الانقاذ انتشال هذه
الفتاه على قيد الحياه نتابع واياكم هذه
التغطيه على امل ان تتكلم هذه العمليه
بالنجاح لان الامل دائما مطلوب
في هذه الاوقات عمار اعود اليك اي جديد في
المشهد من عندك هل من معلومات عن اسم هذه
الطفله عمر هذه الطفله للذين انضموا الينا
الان في التغطيه وتحديدا في اي منطقه من
هاتاي
طالب
للاسف قليلا ولكن تذكيرا للمشاهدين هم
اخبروني وحددوا انها انثى لم يحددوا انها
طفله او كبيره في السن ولكنها انثى طبعا
انا كنت تحدثت الى ضابط سلاح الهندسه
التركي الذي استخدم الجهاز وطلب من هذه
الفتاه المتواجده تحت الانقاض ان تجيبوا
على بعض الاسئله من خلال ردات فعل بالحركه
وبالفعل هي اجابته يعني سالها اسئله وكان
يطلب منها في ان تجيب من خلال الضغط او
الطرق او التحرك بطريقه معينه واعجابته
واكد لي انها على قيد الحياه واكدت لي
احدى
المنقضات ايضا هي هنا انها
فتاوى قيد الحياه وانهم هذا قبل تقريبا 40
دقيقه من الان وانهم خلال ساعه سيصلون
اليها ما حدث بانها يعني قاموا فرق
الانقاذ بفحص من خلال الاجهزه ومن خلال
الحديث المباشر معها وتاكدوا انها على قيد
الحياه بعد 6 ايام قضتها تحت الانقاض وهم
الان في استنفار كبير لديهم هنا اجهزه
لديهم اضاءه لديهم كل ما يريدونه للوصول
اليها قاموا باحداث فتحه في سقف
الجدار وايضا دخلوا من تحت
الجدار دخل احد رجال الانقاذ وهم يعني هذه
شنطه سفر اخرجوها للتو من هذه الغرفه هم
على ما يبدو يحاولون الوصول اليها
بالطريقه سليمه طبعا طالب
قاموا بجلب قطع خشبيه كبيره لا ادري ما
سببها وربما هي
الاخشاب يعني نحن نحاول نحاول الحفر نعم
نحاول يعني هو للدعم فقط لدعم السقوف كي
لا تنهار وهم يحاولون ربما انتشال صحيح
هذه الفتاه
صحيح رايتها للتو حينما وضعوها صحيح صحيح
لا لا انا لا اريد فقط ان افتي من عندي
احاول فقط ان اكون دقيق ما الذي يحدث
لماذا يعني يستعينون بالخشب يعني انا اريد
ان اعرف الان يقصون مثلا الحديث ولديهم
اضاءه واحد رجال الانقاذ في الداخل ولكن
اريد ان اعرف كل شيء وانقل لكم كل شيء
بالتفصيل على ايه حال هم على الاغلب يعني
وحسب ما اخبروني انهم على وشك الوصول
والمهم بالامر ان الفتاه مدركه تماما يعني
حينما طلبوا منها ردات الفعل كانت ملتزمه
بردات الفعل وهذا الامر
تبين معهم عبر الجهاز ومن قام بفحصها هو
ضابط تركي ولا وجود لاي فرق اجنبيه في هذا
الموقع كل من يعملونهم من الاتراك في هذا
المكان لاستخراج هذه الناجيه من تحت
الانقاض بعد سته ايام مع اليوم السادس على
وشك ان ينتهي طبعا هذا الامر طاهر كما
تعلم بحد ذاته ان تكون على قيد الحياه وان
تخرج سليمه اشبه بالمعجزه كبير وعظيم ونحن
يعني نتمنى ان يتم على خير طيب عمار
المبنى المدمر الذي يحاول رجال الانقاذ
الان يعني
ان يفتحوا ثغره من اجل انتشال هذه الفتاه
هل وفق المعلومات كان مبدا كبيرا ام لا
مبنى سكني صغير هذا واحد وفي العاده مثل
هكذا عمليات يعني كم تستمر من الوقت
للوصول الى الناجي
يبدو ان فقدنا يعني مفرد العربيه عمار
الهندي منها طايلاندا عوده اليه بطبيعه
الحال لانه يعني الصوره مؤثره جدا منها
على كل نتابع معكم هذه التغطيه المتواصله
لزلزال سوريا وتركيا اعزائي المشاهدين وهو
الزلزال الذي اقرت الامم المتحده انه اسوا
حدث تشهده المنطقه في مئه عام الرئيس
التركي اعلن منذ بعض الوقت ارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال الى اكثر من 21 الفا اما المرصد
السوري فقد اعلن ارتفاع حصيله قتل الزلزال
في سوريا وحدها الى خمسه الاف ومئتين
وبذلك تجاوز عدد القتلى اكثر من 27 الفا
في كلا البلدين مع ترجيحات بارتفاع العدد
مع تضاؤل فرص العثور على ناجيم بالرغم من
ذلك يبقى الامل موجودا العربيه كانت شاهده
اليوم على انقاذ ثلاثه اطفال من قهرمان
مرعش بعد سته ايام عاشوها تحت الان
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
وحده تسع سنين
الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
الامل في قهرمان مرعش لم ينسحب على جميع
من ينتظر خبرا من تحت الركام عن احبائي
فقد اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول ابا تركيا وهو
يصرخ باسماء افراد عائلته املا في اي
اشاره على بقائهم احياء تحت الالقاب
[موسيقى]
هذا تمكنت فرق البحث والانقاذ فيها طائر
التركيه من العثور على طفل عالق تحت
الانقاض بعد مرور 128 ساعه
الله
اعود الى العربيه عمار الهندي الذي يتابع
عمليه الانقاذ هذه لفتاه تحت هذا المبنى
المدمر بعد اكثر من 130 ساعه على هذا
الزلزال عمار اترك الكلمه لك لتصف لنا
وتنقل لنا الصوره
انا عم طالب كنت اسالني عن هذا المبنى من
هل هو مكون من طبقات نعم هو مكون من طبقات
وفيها عدد كبير من الشقق ولم يجري حتى
اللحظه رفعه بشكل كامل يعني بمعنى هم
بداوا من الاعلى في هذه الحاله التي هي
على قيد الحياه ولكن هذا المبنى فيه
العديد من الجثث والاشخاص تحت الانقاض وهم
يعني بين حينما ينتهوا من هذا من انقاذ
هذه الفتاه بالتاكيد ستستمر اعمالهم في
هذا المبنى
ايضا يعني هنالك سباق مع الزمن مع الوقت
هي خلال هذه العمليات التي تحدث هنا طالب
كنت سالتني ايضا كم تستغرق من الوقت هذه
مثل هذه العمليات انا كنت شهدت يعني عمليه
انقاذ فتاه كانت ثلاث ايام تحت الانقاض
هنا في هاتاي حينما وصلوا اليها استغرق
الامر ساعتين ولكن احيانا كثيره طاهر يحدث
امر غير متوقع وهو محزن يعني بالامس مثلا
كنا في منطقه وكانت هنالك شابه محاميه تحت
الانقاض وكانت تتحدث اليهم يعني كان لديها
انين وتتالم وسمعوه وتاكدوا انها حيه ولكن
الوصول اليها استغرق تقريبا ثلاث ساعات
ونصف حينما وصلوا اليها كانت قد فارقت
الحياه ويعني ابن خالها كان معنا على
العربيه وكان يعني مصدوم بشكل كبير حتى
رجال الانقاذ كانوا في صدمه كبيره ولكن
يعني هذا الذنب ليس ذنبهم ولكن ما يعيق
الوصول اليهم يكون في بعض الاحيان اكبر من
قدراتهم اكبر من الامكانيات ومعقد اكثر من
الامال المعلقه على اخراج شخص من تحت
الانقاض في مثل هذه الحاله لا اعرف تماما
ولكن حسب ما اخبرتني به
منقذه هنا تعمل في هذا الموقع قالت لي
خلال ساعه احنا تجاوزنا الساعه الان يعني
تقريبا ساعه وعشر دقائق وهم يعملون على
هذا الموقع ولكن على ما يبدو لي على ما
يبدو لي انها لن تطول كثيرا لان احد رجال
الانقاذ دخل بالفعل ولديهم الدعامات
ولديهم كل شيء ولديهم الفتحه من السقف
والاخرى من داخل الغرفه من تحت السقف طيب
بتعرف نحن محكومون دائما بالامل والرجاء
عمار لكن اطقم الاغاثه ورجال انقاذ الذين
تتكلم معهم هل هم يعني الان بداوا في
مرحله
لا اريد ان اصفها بالياس انه احتماليه
بقاء ناجين تحت الانقاض بالنسبه اليهم
باتت معدومه او شبه معدومه وانه مرحله
انقاذ اين جين انتهت بالنسبه اليهم لتبدا
مرحله جديده
انا انا اعرف ما تريد ان تقول وانا ايضا
يعني اخشى الوقوع في هذا الامر ولا اريد
ان افكر به انه في لحظه ما يتم الاعلان عن
وقف عمليات او العثور عن الناجين او البحث
عن الناجين في الحقيقه يعني انا رايت
بصراحه يعني رايت بعض الفتور في المعنويات
لدى رجال الانقاذ لانه نحن في اليوم
السادس والدمار كبير وعمليه العثور على
صوت هنا وهناك ليست سهله يعني ليست سهله
ولكن
طالب بمجرد ان يعرفوا ان هنالك صوت ويتاكد
منه لتكون هنالك معنويات واستنفار كبير
كما يحدث هذا في هذا الموقع انا اليوم
سالت احد المنقذين من طقم من طاقم اجنبي
وليس تركي اخبرته كان هنالك من من يتحدث
بان هنالك شخص ناجن تحت الانقاذ اخبرني
قال نو ساونز يعني خلاص انهم بمجرد انه لا
هنا ليس هنا الاصوات تتوقف عمليات البحث
ويعني هذا امر للحقيقه يعني يدلل على انه
لو اثبتت الاجهزه مثلا مثلا ان هنالك
استشعار حراري لشخص تحت الانقاد على قيد
الحياه ربما ربما يعني هم يعتمدون مبدا
العثور على الصوت والتاكد منه حتى تتم كل
هذه العمليه خشيه ان تكون هذا الرصد
للحراره شيء مختلف وليس لشخص ناجن مثلا
يعني انا كذا فسرت الامر ولكن نعم ولكن في
مثل هذه الحاله التي نشهدها الان مباشره
على الهواء لا هم بمجرد ان اكد
الضابط العسكري من سلاح الهندسه ان انها
حيه بدا استنفار كبير جدا وجاء التعزيزات
والاضاءه والاجهزه التي تقطع
الحديد وكل شيء يعني فبالتالي الامر نعم
الامر حتى طريقه استنصار رجال الانق طريقه
عملهم عمار يعني بهذه الطريقه التي
نشاهدها تؤكد انه ما زال هنالك احياء تحت
الانقاض يعني في هنالك هنالك يعني شيء حي
تحت الانقاض وهم يحاولون استخراج هذه
الفتاه او هذا
الشخص كذلك ايضا في الصوره المقابله ايضا
في قهرمان مرعش
هنالك ايضا
فرق انقاذ في
ومحاوله لانتشال بعض
الناجين ايضا يعني حتى برغم مرور كل هذه
المده سته ايام اكثر من 130 ساعه ما زالت
تسمع بعض
الاصوات
غسان ابو لوز موجود معنا ايضا سنكون معه
بعد قليل من قهرمان مرعش ولكن اعود الى
عمار عمار طيب الظروف المح حاله طقس
درجات الحراره كلها تساعد الان ام لا
تلاحظ انه المساله يعني التنقيب بهذا
الشكل الحفر بهذه الظروف صعب جدا لذلك
ياخذ كل هذا الوقت
درجات الحراره ساعات المساء يعني الان
بارده جدا جدا يا طاهر حقيقه ولكن لا
اعتقد انها تشكل حاليا فارق بالنسبه
لرجال الانقاذ كل ما يعيقهم ويؤخرهم هو ما
يعترضهم في طريقهم الى هذه الفتاه التي
يعني
تفصلها مسافه قليله جدا عن العوده للحياه
ولكن هذه المسافه تعترضها بعض قطع الحديد
ربما والقطاع الخرسانيه وبالتالي يعني هم
يعني يعملون لقطع هذه المسافه الضئيله
المعقده جدا
والتي تعترضهم فيها اشياء هم يعني يعني هم
خبراء فيها ولكن يقف الانسان احيانا عاجز
امام شيء بسيط جدا اصغر الامور اكبرها في
احيان كثيره طالب ولذلك يعني هم يتاخرون
واعتقد ان هذا التاخير وهذه الدقه في
العمل مهمه لسبب واحد خشيه ان يعني ان
يرتكب رجال الانقاذ او العمليات في هذه
العمليات خطا فيؤدي الى مثلا مشكله في
حياه هذه الفتاه التي تنتظر ان يلتقطها
احد ويعدها الى حياتها الطبيعيه يعني وانت
تتحدث عمار او اذكر انه
مفردنا ايضا غسان ابو لوز على الحدث يتابع
عمليه انقاذ لاحد الاشخاص من تحت احد
المباني مهدم كليا ايضا هنالك حديث عن
وجود ناجين وبالتالي نشاهد الدعمات
الخشبيه لبعض رجال الانقاذ تدخل الان
لتدعيم بعض
الجدران كي لا تنهار على فرق الانقاذ
الذين يدخلون الى هذا المبنى نشاهد الان
بام العين يعني هذه الدعامات الخشبيه التي
تدخل على هذا المبنى في قهرمان مرعش
بالنسبه الى
هاتاي نعود الى عمار عمار طيب عندما يتم
التاكد ان هذا المبنى لا يوجد فيه نجيم
كيف يتم التعامل معه يعني باي طريقه انه
مبنى مهدم وتاكد رجال الانقاذ انه لا يوجد
فيه ناجين هل يتم جرفه سريعا وازاله
الركام ام لا في الاولويه
ارجو ان تشرح عمار
لا تكون له الاولويه لانه انا اليوم
استمعت وهذا موضوع مهم جدا وانا اختصرت لك
الامر فقلت لفعلا لا تكون له الاولويه انا
اليهود اليوم زرت اربع او خمس مواقع مدمره
وفي تحتها اشخاص تاكدوا تماما انه لا حياه
لهم وانهم فارقوا الحياه تماما واخبر احد
رجال الانقاذ شخص من ذويهم بان الاولويه
الان للبنيات التي يتواجد فيها اشخاص على
قيد الحياه ونحن متاكدون من ذلك وبالتالي
ظهر معنا يعني هو هذا الشاب كان معي على
الهواء على شاشه الحدث وناشد بانه لا يريد
اكثر من الحصول على جثامين عائلته لدفنها
ويعني هو يطالب بسرعه
ازاله الانقاض في تحت في هذه البنايات
التي تاكدوا انهم اموات وهو متاكد نفسه
لانه هو حفر بيده ونزل وظهرت له بعض الجثث
وبالتالي هو يعلم انه لا حياه في لاحد تحت
هذه الالقاب ولكن في الاخر في النهايه
الاولويه كما قلت لك للبنايات التي فيها
احياء يقوموا بالعمل فيها اولا وبعد ذلك
يتوجهوا الى تلك البنايات التي ليس فيها
ناجين ليس فيها احياء وتكون ولكن بالتاكيد
يعني يعود اليها سيعمل على ازالتها ولكن
الاولويه كما قلت لك وهنا سؤال كبير جدا
لماذا لانه طبعا فرق الانقاذ غير كافيه
الاعداد غير كافيه
وتسابق الزمن لتبحث عن اي موقع فيه ناجي
نعم طيب عمار في يعني عم نشوف في اختلاف
في الطرق في التعاطي مع المبنى المهدم
يعني في بعض المباني عم بيكون في عم يشوف
رافعه عم نشوف جرافه عم اشوف اليات ثقيله
في بعض المباني عم نشوف رجال انقاذ بمعدات
متوسطه في بعض الاخر لا عم اشوف بوسائل لا
اريد ان اقول بدائيه ولكن مرات حتى الحفر
بالايدي على اي اساس تختلف ط
يعني البحث عن ناجين يعني هذا بيستخدم هذه
الالات البعض بيستخدم لا الات متوسطه
البعض الاخر لا يعني
مجرد ازميل او حتى بالايدي
هنالك تفسير لهذه لهذا الاختلاف طالب
حينما تكون البنايه
اخرجت الجثث او الجثامين التي تحتها تتدخل
الاليات الثقيله لازاله هذا الركام يعني
ونقله تنتهي خلاص يعني تعود على الارض هذه
البنايه في حال كانت البنايه على سبيل
المثال
تعترض فرق الانقاذ طريقها مثلا اسقف هذه
البنايه تاتي الاليات الكبيره تحطمها
ويبدا من بعد تتوقف وتبدا عمليه البحث عن
مفقودين سواء احياء او اموات وبالتالي
تختفي تختلف الاليه والمعدات التي يعملون
بها ولكن في اي مبنى يتواجد فيه شخص على
قيد الحياه تتوقف كليا للاليات الكبيره لا
تعمل بشكل نهائي لحين ضمان اخراج هذا
الشخص لانه اي عمل لاليات ثقيله في هذا
المبنى يمكن ان يهدم اجزاء منها وبالتالي
تفشل الانقاذ وبالتالي هذا كله رهين بمن
تحت
هذا كله رهين باجابه على على تساؤلات
متعدده هل يوجد احياء تحت البنايه هل يوجد
جثامين لاموات يجب اخراجها ام لا يوجد احد
في اي حاله من الحالات الثلاثه هذه تختلف
الاليات وتختلف الاساليب وتختلف المعدات
المستخدمه في العمل عمار ايضا يعني حتى
بالنسبه الى رجال الانقاذ يعني هم يعملون
بظروف غير طبيعيه وخطره يعني ما زالت
هنالك هزات ارتداديه وفي
المشاهد اللي اوردناها منذ قليل انه
كالرجال الانقاذ عم بحاولوا انتشال بعض
الناجين حصلت هزه ارتداديه فانهار المبنى
عليهم طيب اي اجراءات احترازيه ياخذها
يعني عندما تتابعهم هم يعني اتخذوا كل
الاجراءات الاحترازيه بمعنى حتى لو حصلت
هزه ارتداديه فلن يكونوا هم معرضين للخطر
او الذين يحاولون انتشالهم
[موسيقى]
طالب انا طلب منا ان نصمت قليلا ساصمت
قليلا عذرا ولكن الصوره معك لان رجال
الانقاذ طلبوا اوكي نشاهد ايضا كما ذكر
عمار الهندي
الفرق الانقاذ طلبت من الجميع السكوت من
اجل تلقي اي اشاره لهذه الناجيه منها طاي
حتى انه تم اطفاء الاضاءه اذا تم اطفاء
الاضاءه نشاهد ما زلنا نشاهد رجال الانقاذ
ولكن تم اطفاء النور والاضاءه
وطلب من الجميع السكوت التام من اجل رصد
اي حركه او اي صوت لهذه الناجيه بالطبع من
اجل تحديد مكانها بدقه لكي يتمكن رجال
الانقاذ من الوصول اليها الزميل عمار
الهندي قال انه احد رجال الانقاذ دخل يعني
في هذه الفتحه من اجل الوصول اليها وقد تم
تدعيم هذه الفتحه كما شاهدنا
في عدد
من الاخشاب يعني او الاعمده الخشبيه
مخافه او مغبه اي انهيار
نلاحظ الان يعني احد رجال انقاذ خرج يتكلم
مع زميله ولكن الاضاءه كما كنا نشاهدها
اطفئت تماما هنالك اضاءه بسيطه فقط من
الخوذه من على راس رجل الانقاذ الذي يدخل
مجددا ولكن كان هنالك هذا الضوء
الساطع الذي كنا نشاهده ويعطينا صوره اكبر
واوضح لما يجري في عمليه الانقاذ هذه تم
اطفائه وتم الطلب من الجميع السكوت تماما
من اجل رصد اي حركه
لهذه الناجيه من تحت الانقاض كما ذكر عمار
الهندي انها انثى امراه الان عادت الاضاءه
لنعد الى عمار اذا كان يسمعني عمار هل عرف
هل تسنى لك يعني معرفه اي شيء لانه
الاضاءه عادت وعاد الجميع الى
التحدث والتكلم نعم هم
على ما يبدو هو تعمد ان يطفئ الاضواء
كامله لان يريد ان يشاهد من خلال الضوء
البسيط الذي يمسكه بيده ماذا يوجد داخل
الحجره التي دخل اليها الغرفه تحت السقف
التي دخل اليها وطلب الصمت لعله يستمع الى
امور ولكنه بعد ذلك يعني اكد ان
بضروره استئناف العمل من جديد وانا اشاهد
طبعا العمليه معقده جدا طالب وليست سهله
عليهم على رجال الانقاذ يعني هذا الصمت
الذي يطلبونه
يكون فعلا بمس الحاجه الى صمت ويكون فعلا
اقترب من شيء معين يريد ان يستمع ويتاكد
انه وصل الى النقطه حساسه في الوصول الى
تلك الفتاه على ايه حال كنت ايضا سالتني
انت عن رجال الانقاذ ومهماتهم والخطر الذي
المحدق الذي يحيط بهم خلال عملهم بجوار
البنايات